you brought out our country back now  it's time your time to secure the gains  and move ahead and you know what America  can't succeed unless you succeed that is  why I am running for president of  I'm running to make our economy work for  you and for every American now there may  be some new voices in the presidential  Republican choir  but they're all singing the same old  song a song called yesterday  I've stood up to adversaries like Putin  and reinforced allies like Israel and I  was in the situation room on the day we  got bin Laden it is way past time to end  the outrage of so many women still  earning less than men on the job and  women of color often making even less  you do your part you reap the rewards  where we don't leave anyone out or  anyone behind an America where a father  can tell his daughter yes you can be  anything you want to be even President  of the United States thank you god bless  you and may God bless america